nervous about whether debit and credit
cards might stop working as sanctions
bite some russians are stocking up on
cash
soon they'll begin to feel the financial
pain of their president's decision to
invade ukraine with interest rates more
than doubled 20
and the ruble plunging 30 percent
against the dollar
no we are planning to buy a flat so for
us it is very important we were hoping
to have a certain interest rate now it
will be totally different
of course i am worried first of all the
situation with the dollar is unclear and
what about food prices we are in a
dead-end situation there is no way out
for people russians have been promised
that central bank reserves of more than
630 billion dollars will help cushion
the economy from sanctions
but much of this money is in foreign
banks sanctions will make it very
difficult to get any of it back to
moscow
one russian economist told al jazeera
it's a completely unprecedented
situation for the central bank on friday
central bank had enormous reserves today
half of this resorts are frozen and the
other half is likely to be unusable as
well so this is something where nobody
really can imagine what's going on the
central bank says external conditions
for the russian economy have drastically
changed
in a meeting about sanctions with
government ministers vladimir putin
described the western community as an
empire of lies
russia's economy is also taking a hit
from western firms running for the exit
bp the biggest foreign investor here is
abandoning its stake in oil firm rosneft
ups and fedex have stopped shipping
services half the passenger jets used
here are leased and those contracts are
being cancelled russia's political
economic and physical isolation from the
rest of the world is rapidly gathering
pace
bernard smith al jazeera moscow